[Music]
you don't have to be a movie buff maybe
you don't even like movies that much but
everyone has heard of the name Quentin
Tarantino
he is without a doubt one of the most
celebrated directors of our time with
each of his eight iconic works making a
profound impact on the history of cinema
and inspiring generations of filmmakers
with a vastly new style and approach to
filmmaking I can only be described as
Tarantino esque which by the way is now
an official entry in the Oxford English
Dictionary so what makes the films of
Quentin Tarantino so special many often
cite his razor-sharp dialogue in a bar
called a the often graphic yet stylized
violence or his use of nonlinear
narrative structure but what truly sets
him apart from every other filmmaker
it's the way in which he steals from
other movies and that's not just a
figure of speech in a 1994 interview
with Empire Magazine Tarantino said I
steal from every single movie ever made
Tarantino's visual references to movies
have become his trademark some of these
references are merely hinted at the DSM
while others are almost identical
replications for this reason he's been
the center of controversy for many years
for example in 1997 his debut film
Reservoir Dogs was under heavy scrutiny
after a critic accused Tarantino of
plagiarizing the 1987 Hong Kong crime
film city on fire the final 20 minutes
of city on fire is essentially identical
to the plot of Reservoir Dogs and there
are shots and moments scattered
throughout that directly resemble each
other
including this famous Mexican standoff
sequence but it's not just in this film
almost all of Tarantino's eight films
have a main source of inspiration for
Jackie Brown it was the 1974 film Foxy
Brown for Kill Bill
the 1973 Japanese film ladies snow blood
and his inglorious basterds is in a lot
of ways similar to the 1967 war film The
Dirty Dozen and on top of that each film
has more visual references to at least
another dozen movies many consider these
similarities Amadas a practice as long
as the history of cinema itself a way
for Tarantino to pay respect to the
movies he loves but Tarantino explicitly
denies this in the same interview he
goes on to say great artists steal they
don't do lodges it's a quote that
closely resembles words attributed to
another famous artist Pablo Picasso was
often quoted as having said good artists
copy and great artists steal to
understand why and how Tarantino steals
it's important to understand his
background Tarantino's career in film
didn't start in a classroom or even a
movie set but a video store where he
worked as a clerk and gained a
reputation for his almost encyclopedic
knowledge of cinema in other words
Tarantino was never taught how to make a
film instead he learned how to make
films by watching them which makes it
natural that imitation became his main
source of inspiration in style in fact
if you take a look at most of
Tarantino's screenplays they begin with
a list of filmmakers whom the stories
were inspired by and dedicated to I
think the reason why Tarantino is so
proud to admit that he is stealing is
because he accomplishes something with
it that no other filmmaker is quite
capable of creating something new and as
paradoxical as it may sound Tarantino's
movies have a sense of originality to
them
despite their many sources of
inspiration this is why Tarantino is
often hailed as one of the
quintessential filmmakers of
post-modernism post-modernism in film
describes an era when filmmakers began
questioning the ways in which mainstream
movies are made and told and began
making movies that went directly against
one of the central tenets of
post-modernism is the idea that nothing
is new in art everything is recycled and
reused over and over again Reservoir
Dogs might have stolen the Mexican
standoff from City on fire but city on
fire also stole it from the 1966 film
the good the bad and the ugly and pop
fiction is no exception it's chock-full
of references to classical movies
especially movies from the French New
Wave movement one of the most
influential movements in the history of
cinema in which young filmmakers also
tried to challenge the traditional
method of filmmaking its famous dancing
sequence was inspired by this sequence
from the 1964 film Band of Outsiders and
the choreography closely resembles this
scene from the 1963 film eight and a
half but that's not the only source it
steals from John Travolta's dance was
inspired by this scene from 1966
adaptation of Batman while uma thurman's
dancing resembles that of a cat in the
1970 animated film the Aristocats and
throughout the rest of the film as well
the mysterious suitcase that carries the
plot of the film is a replication from
the 1955 American film Kiss Me Deadly
and of course this scene was inspired by
Alfred Hitchcock's Psycho
what makes Tarantino so special is that
he never steals from one source he
rather steals from multiple sources
spanning decades and then stitches them
together to create something new it's a
technique known as pastiche a vital
element in post-modernism most people
are more familiar with this technique
through another medium music especially
in the hip hop genre where artists use
sampling to take part of an existing
song to create something new
[Music]
just like Tarantino it's been the
subject of controversy many times
Tarantino's pastiche works so well
because of two reasons one is his
understanding of the subject he's
stealing from more often than not oh ma
jizz in movies are a shallow and vain
attempt at imitating an iconic moment
and they rarely serve a purpose but
Tarantino's references are often
seamless and easy to miss because they
enhance the scenes and the genre he
experiments with and if you take a look
at Tarantino's career each of his eight
films is a tribute to a specific genre
and movement in cinema Reservoir Dogs is
a pastiche of the gritty Hong Kong crime
films and pulp fiction is based on the
unconventional French New Wave movement
Jackie Brown bases itself off the 70s
controversial blaxploitation films while
Kill Bill is reminiscent of the
classical Japanese samurai and Chinese
consul movies death Proof pays tribute
to low-budget exploitation movies while
inglorious basterds references world war
ii cinema and his two most recent films
Django Unchained and the hateful eight
our modern takes of the Italian
spaghetti westerns Tarantino seamlessly
blends all these genres and inspirations
through his unique vision and writing
this is where his razor-sharp dialogue
comes in generally you have my curiosity
now you have my attention it's not an
exaggeration to say that Tarantino's
films are essentially re-adaptation zuv
classical films and genres that take
place in a world of Tarantino where
violence injustice sex and satirical
cynicism flourish Quentin Tarantino
perhaps knows better than anyone that
you don't have to look far for
inspiration most of the time it might be
somewhere close and familiar to us my
guess is that for Tarantino it's in the
aisles of VHS tapes that he grew up
watching as a child
Tarantino proudly plays the role of a
masterful thief of cinema and as long as
he continues to make a masterpiece out
of them it's the kind of thievery I'd be
more than happy to accept
[Music]
you